we can't be the only ones
obsessed with shadow and bone and the
grishavers between the magic
romance and the most adorable cast we
just can't get enough
which is why we're crossing the fold and
heading behind the scenes of this
netflix series to uncover how the show
really looks without cgi magic
how did they manage to bring things like
the fight sequences sun summoner's
powers and realistic sets to life
let's find out doing weight sessions
together we're going to fight each other
in the end so it's kind of built that up
nicely
elena almost getting kidnapped in the
forest early on in season one
is one of the very first battle scenes
we got to see come to life
it was so epic that we bet you couldn't
have guessed that it was filmed with
barely any physical weapons
while some of the actors were of course
holding prop weapons
the ones we see flying through the air
like this axe
weren't there during the filming actors
were given the marks they were supposed
to hit and told where the weapons were
generally going to land
the rest was all added in during the
editing with visual effects
i've survived long enough without
protection thank you how could something
that looks so real
be so fake that's how we're feeling
after finding out that the grisha magic
in shadow and bone was all done using
visual effects
the actors were given choreography just
like a fight sequence
on how to move their hands and bodies in
a way that would let them add in magic
afterward they even choreographed these
movements into the actual fight
sequences
check out this clip of the stunt
coordinators mapping out a magical
action-filled scene
jesper and his gun go hand-in-hand some
fans would even say they're one in the
same
which means actor kit young had his work
cut out for him when it came to
performing jasper's classic tricks
yup all those impressive movements you
see in the show were done by kit himself
at first things didn't go very well and
believe it or not
kit couldn't even hold the gun properly
i immediately dropped one
and it smashed everywhere but after some
intense practice including a trip to the
shooting range
he eventually became a pro you can even
see his progress throughout the episodes
in the first few his tricks were pretty
minor compared to the elaborate ones we
see at the end of season one
unfortunately they weren't born into the
crows which means actors amita suman and
freddy carter had a lot of work to do in
order to prepare for their characters
inej and kaz
especially when it came to their props
inej is a master with her knives
but we guess you could say she was a
little off balanced before going through
training
the same went for kaz and his cane the
two of them had to get used to the
weight of the prop weapons and how to
move with them so that they'd be able to
execute some pretty intense fight scenes
check out some of their behind the
scenes training sessions with their
stunt trainers
it's gonna be rough going through
airport security oh yeah
kaz's kane is such an important part of
his character which meant the filmmakers
had to make it look
perfect in the series the cane was
purposely made to be able to break other
human bones
dark we know when you look at a prop
without movie magic you can tell that it
wasn't constructed using some heavy duty
material
which is why they use visual effects on
the cane to make it extra extravagant on
screen
it's not a huge difference but it
definitely adds to the realism of the
grishaverse
this is something else did anyone else
cringe when the darkling embedded
the stag antlers underneath alina's skin
while an antler necklace might have been
the more eye pleasing way to go
it went against the set safety protocols
so instead
they created a prosthetic made out of a
soft material
it might have been more cautionary but
it was anything but comfortable for
actress jessie maylie
she complained it was so itchy i was
always accidentally picking it
i can't be trusted with a prosthetic she
wasn't even given a pass when she wore
clothes that covered her collar bones
they had a second type of prosthetic
specifically for that
poor jesse instead you may need this
a trip through the fold is no walk in
the park
but the boat they rode on through the
fold is pretty cool
and that's because during filming they
used an actual boat
you can see in these behind the scenes
videos and photos how detailed the
show's crew were able to make this huge
prop
however that was the only real thing
about these scenes
the fold itself was added in later using
visual effects and the same goes for the
attacking vulcara
mal and alina being picked up by the
volcara were actually just them wearing
harnesses while being attached to a wire
zorya i've been training her since she
was 10.
the cast got down and dirty when it came
to fighting in a more traditional style
for the most part all of the cast did
their own stunts which meant that they
all had to hit the gym during their time
in budapest
they would also have training sessions
with the stunt coordinators to make sure
they all got the choreography down
luckily the cast was more than happy to
comply
mal's journey to find the stag led him
to a dangerous winter wonderland
we'd guess it was filmed on location but
it was actually in the studio
they had fake snow on the ground and
were surrounded by a huge green screen
wondering how they got all them covered
in snow with a snow blower of course
and by the looks of it they had a lot of
fun in comparison to their characters
is that we interrupt your regular
broadcast to introduce you to the shadow
and bonecast dance breaks
amongst all the seriousness and hard
work they put in
there was always time for fun with this
cast it's not surprising seeing this
behind the scenes footage
from the most adorable selfies on
instagram to the cast pizza parties
we'd expect nothing less
it could be hard to catch all the
details added in by the set designers
and
show runners but we can assure you that
they put their all into the show
you've probably already noticed that new
languages were created for the series
well these different languages were
printed on labels signs
and anything else that was on set of
shadow and bone there are also signs and
symbols that pay homage to the
characters
did you catch the bird that is identical
to the tattoo inej has
doesn't exist yet do you remember when
imej pulled out her impressive pricks in
this scene
we're still not over it well it was all
amita
even she was shocked that they kept her
version of the scene over the one her
stunt double did
although she didn't walk away unscathed
amita came out of it with a battle scar
that she still wears proudly today
what are your talents what would set
life be without some pranks and joking
around
especially with such a lively cast from
scare fails to trailer catwalks
where kind of jealous we weren't on set
having fun with this cast
it's no surprise amita says she grew so
close and formed such a strong
connection with everyone
as a friend once said if i can't crack
this none of us are going anywhere
if you were paying close attention
during this scene you book lovers might
have noticed a cameo
the author of the shadow and bone book
series lee bardugo became part of the
second order for an episode
it's safe to say from her instagram
posts she was very
excited about it however maybe not too
excited considering she's been asking to
reprise the role in a potential season
two
but only so that she can meet her demise
yeah we're a little confused here lee
she is elena starkov overall the
inspiration for the series and the
imagery it created was actually
gladiator
the showrunners and creative team just
wanted to bring something that was
natural
clean and tangible to life we're going
to say they achieved their goals
you were perfect is shadow and bone
still as magical to you after seeing how
it was really made
we say yes the talent of this editing
team is nothing short of magical
and the bond between the cast makes it
even more impressive
what scene were you most shocked to see
being filmed without its cgi
you